[Music]
in parent-teacher conflict news oh oh
submitted by lost in IKEA tan dude I
don't know how cuz it's just one way but
they have shortcuts though even the
shortcut that they have a [ __ ] do I get
out of here arrows everything but that's
why they build restaurants in there
because they used to just find skeletons
in places cuz he lost a parent mowed
down a teacher in a fit of rage when he
was told he couldn't use the staff
parking lot with a vehicle with a
vehicle that is called conflict
resolution I like it I can't
yes so this parent is dad his name is
Rainier it's 23 years old he went to go
pick up his girlfriend's daughter from
school 22 years old he's 22 and his
girlfriend's daughter is how old I don't
even know if it's a girlfriend cuz they
say partner it might be boyfriend I
don't know but anyway married I don't
know or married true I don't know what's
his sign what's the session illogical
great you said partner's daughter I
think this is in the UK I don't know the
way there oh yeah they use it the cowboy
way like his homie like you're in Texas
you see partner all the time partner
partner no sorry I'm just a Texan cuz I
was conceived there so I was trying to
you're a Texan for [ __ ] generally to a
fellow Texan enlistment can't claim it
says that once you go pick up the
daughter and when he showed up he was
met by a school employee saying that he
couldn't go into the staff parking lot
because they had recently sent out a
notice saying that cars were no longer
allowed to go inside for the safety of
the student sounds like a reasonable
request yeah and so there was a sound
like a bunch of [ __ ] to be neutered
what is the [ __ ] oh just trying to
park my freaking car pick up my my
partner's kids sounds like a Texan Amina
see what's that parking though not Burt
I'm just trying to get this guy's head
you know saying yeah but then it says
that she was in the backseat by the time
he did this to the to the school
employees something like I don't get
but anyway news I'll show you guys the
clip it's 20 seconds long maybe she was
in the back of the whole time yeah
apparently she was in the car when he
did this so here we go so here he is
pulling up and I can't go get it does it
looks like you're not supposed to be in
there if you're not stopped yeah and
then kids go out through here - what was
her bouncer here Oh cuz they had just
recently sent a notice saying that you
can't go a new rule to kids on the bike
- what is it - leave or is it does it go
in what's gonna happen yeah what was
next
wait wait how come oh no cuz students
are leaving out to that gate that's why
they're not closing that gate right yeah
we don't know we don't know [ __ ] yeah we
don't know as always do real research we
make it up yeah we make everything
closed did is the teach alright or the
staff guy look what you kind of gently
kind of picked her up and said get the
[ __ ] out the way right so yeah so he was
jailed for 10 months
and yeah he's going to prison so that's
crazy for this whole incident
they said that he did admit causing
actual bodily harm dangerous driving and
driving without insurance because he was
driving his partners a car which he's
not covered in the insurance and also
having no MOT after the incident I don't
know what of transportation I know
that's what he he admitted to and so he
also put minors in danger to all the
kids on the bikes and stuff yeah he did
and those boys weren't wearing helmets
right and he was kind of like
obstructing traffic too because so many
people cars trying to drive around him
as he was like blocking you should have
gone straight and left yeah I think a
beheading would be okay he looks like a
[ __ ] GTA kind of guy
Rainier no he actually looks like a
whistleblower or something yeah he looks
like Edward Snowden yeah he's like work
for the Secret Service he looks like a
cross between Edward Snowden and the
Prison Break guy oh yeah yeah I'm Sam
what if um the administrator was just
talking mad [ __ ] like he's not even nice
about it he's like are you [ __ ]
you know you know something [ __ ] up
like well [ __ ] you
yeah well he did have scratches on his
head cuz when he fell off the car he
landed and like hit his head it's fine
but the dudes going to prison
so what ten months ten months for a
little baby ride baby ride is a little
bit you know a carnival ride there's a
cat who did probably last time who like
really really hit someone turned into a
speedboat you know I know it you think I
think it's because he was out of school
though everyone's like that everything
at a school is like wayward hiding
someone someone got smacked over the
head with a crowbar and if you went to
jail for assault it three months and
this guy gets ten for doing well what if
these are your kids though you saw that
you saw that that's a toughen up you
little [ __ ] you didn't even get come
close to hitting you yeah I mean there's
a difference between actually getting
hit and almost getting hit yeah respond
I almost died every single day in Los
Angeles County traffic every single day
some [ __ ] tries to merge into my lane
at 65 miles an hour how many times it
happens to you every day I'm on the
breaks like every week at least I feel
like veer into the other lane all the
time because I'm always this [ __ ] those
kids are fine dude I'm so used to that
that the things that she gets scared of
in in the freeway I'm just like oh okay
you don't experience that in Texas
although roses wider they don't drive
like they don't really know constantly
get this in Texas they just drive
straight and then they get off and then
motorcycles don't lane split yeah we
don't do lanes only California I think
that is legal lane splitting
but you know what else though is you
know Texas are super nice right but
they're meaner when it comes to like oh
I made a mistake I got a I got a come in
here they will let you in yeah that's
because everyone in Texas is packing so
it's like there you gotta be got to be
nice that's why everyone's so nice
absolutely
it's like someone merges into your lane
it's like hey that's okay I know you
have a gun it's okay it's chill more
polite dude you think you're going
you're getting in a bar fight if
everyone's on no no no one was escalated
now dude yeah I'd be down with that like
you think yeah you think twice yeah so
this dude was sentenced to like I said
10:1 from prison also with a two year in
five month disqualification from driving
followed by a bended test and he was
also ordered to pay the victim a
surcharge of 148 British pounds [ __ ] he
gets it in an uber to pick up his kid
and then the guys standing in the thing
and he's like yo yo [ __ ] just running
just go go you drop like [ __ ] dude just
[ __ ] go over the dude just me I
should know yeah I know trust me
you again howdy-do folks thank you so
much for watching don't forget to
subscribe to stay up on their most
recent upload and any other cool content
that we put up there and hit the
subscribe button for the last video
click up here